for decades this production line in
france churned out diesel and petrol
engines for cars and vans this is about
to change today employees on the shop
floor are learning a new skill
how to assemble electric motors
[Applause]
the eu is mapping out the route to net
zero greenhouse emissions by 2050
by the end of this decade the goal is a
55 reduction of greenhouse gases
compared to 1990 levels the green deals
fit the 55 plan
road transport currently accounts for
about 20 percent of the eu's co2
emissions and meps are looking at how to
reduce that progressively and fairly
this regulation is about setting
standards for
how much co2 a car can emit and we are
trying that in 2035 all the new cars
that are sold cannot emit co2 anymore so
that means that the car should be
battery electric or for example run on
hydrogen
the cost of running an electric vehicle
is already much lower than its internal
combustion equivalent and with
manufacturers ramping up production of
zero emissions vehicles battery electric
and even hydrogen cars are becoming
cheaper every year
members of parliament want to see that
cost continue to fall along with more
charging points throughout the eu
in 2020 11 of new vehicle registrations
in the eu were electric and market share
is growing
the transition is gathering pace
[Music]